[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
do me a favor and read what tom segura
wrote about about
okay this is at tom segura right
1 33 p.m [ __ ] will smith's candy ass
smacking a dude four inches shorter and
50 pounds lighter okay don't necessarily
disagree he's just in his feelings
because his bald-headed well i don't
know if i should really be saving this
because if if someone just clips the
front then i'm saying it but anyways
he's just in his feelings because his
bald-headed
[ __ ] been [ __ ] around on him for
years and he takes it we all know who he
wishes he could slap
hashtag [ __ ] will wow
so sugar's on the fence yes sigurd's on
the fence shagora is being a little a
little bit ambiguous
i just i just by the way this is my
business partner okay right right like
so hey man we have a movie in the works
like what the [ __ ] are you doing right
so i feel chris rock is
making fun of will smith in a very
polite like it's very vanilla way yeah
he casually i realize now just on the
fly looks at jada who's bald and says
i can't wait to see you in g.i jane too
yeah
andrew it's a throwaway andrew that's it
yeah these [ __ ] are acting like
they acting like chris rock was like and
your bald [ __ ] wife
um dude i am more outraged today than i
was
before because you never even saw it you
just heard about realize
how vanilla
he did a dad joke well here's what's
funny a lot of dads a lot of people are
saying it's a bad joke which is also
true it is a bad joke it's a corny dance
it's a corny joke yeah
but but like how do you even get mad at
a bad joke what he's always in his rap
songs he never swears and he always
tries to say wholesome yeah yeah they'll
swear at the oscars you know the guy's a
fraud
nicest guy hollywood no wonder his wife
keeps on cheating on him
the problem wasn't the slap the slap was
just someone losing their temper the
apology just sucked the apology was just
like he apologized to the academy he
apologized to his fellow actors yeah
like what they didn't get bloody hit in
the face apologize chris nothing
happened he got to sit back and he said
what i didn't like was the actors all
stood up and applauded him and they all
comforted him and then on the e
entertainment afterwards they were going
oh this ruined wills moment no no
someone should have yelled out saying
say sorry to chris you know what i mean
or
or just stayed seated or done something
some some minor protest man that was
wild [ __ ] left on television next year
the archer's gonna be produced by dana
white yeah
even putin was watching that [ __ ] going
dude little violent over there huh holy
hell i did see people online that were
like
you know she's been very vocal about
alopecia
and
you're and then people are like
struggling with this disease or whatever
they've used terms like
dude zero people are dying from alopecia
you just lose a little bit of hair check
it out check it out
i don't care yeah my hair is orange and
it's thinning so do i get
who do you get to slap yeah
you know what i'm saying who do you get
inside of somebody's like oh look at
this ginger it's like a lot of people
are suffering with ginger yeah
gingeritis is a serious disease again to
me that's not the issue
stop talking about alopecia
can we be 100 yeah chris rock made a
dumb dad joke in the moment
not thinking about nothing else other
than here's a glamorous black woman
dressed to the nines with her rich ass
husband and they're both successful and
he's just making fun that's all it was
yeah [ __ ] stop talking about alopecia
[ __ ] off by the way the alopecia
foundation is like yes they're getting
so much attention right well actually
you know sandler retweeted chris rock's
tour he was like love you buddy and he
retweeted the tickets for and the tour
oh i saw this like yeah i saw this thing
that was like it's sold out in like
seconds oh people were so excited to go
see him cause i didn't want to see him
clown he should name the [ __ ] jada you
know what i'm saying
unless he can flip it in this new tour
now he can't flip it and talk [ __ ] about
will but he's got to be able to make
jokes about it to the point where he can
like address it in a way where we go i
guess that was kind of funny and your
reaction was reasonable because right
now the reaction looks soft not saying
he should go and [ __ ] beat the [ __ ]
at him but there he should have been
like told what to do and then
immediately capitulate he should have
just sat there and also like [ __ ]
continued to read the teleprompter
like
he should have stopped the [ __ ] thing
and said get him out of there
he just slapped me i'm being
professional because i don't want to
ruin this award for everybody else
that's here and i don't want to ruin
this night but he's not allowed to slap
me and just keep staying here for the
rest of the show and you at least say
that offstage but it's also so tough to
tell somebody how you would react when
that happens because not only did you
get slapped there's no way you thought
you were actually going to go
and then by the time you process what
happens he's back in his chair yelling
and you're just like what yeah i have so
much empathy for you just slap what the
[ __ ] yeah like you said this has
happened to you yeah you got slapped and
you're like what there's no clap for you
you just cannot believe it do you have
jane joker you go up you smack a guy in
the face
chris handled it i and here's the other
thing i feel like when they were going
like this is going to open a door
for people coming home it's like that's
been happening
yeah i gotta
there's nothing worse than security at a
[ __ ] comedy club my favorite thing
ever the amount of times somebody came
up on stage and i'm looking like i
remember doing i've never been in danger
fields
and having the mic stand going you can't
come up here you can't come up here and
i'm looking out at the bar those three
jackasses and suits are just sitting
there watching like it was part of the
[ __ ] show and the worst thing is when
they go to kick somebody out all they do
is just get them on the other side of
the door and they're like this
and then they turn their back and the
guy always gets back in dude i had like
three guys that wanted to beat the [ __ ]
out of me and on separate occasions and
they ended up standing in the line
like waiting to beat me up
when i was selling merch that's how dumb
they were and i'm looking up and they're
like five guys away and i'm looking at
the bouncer like i thought you threw
that [ __ ] guy out oh my god why did
he get back in here he walked right
through the front door again i was
watching on american tv
and they dumped the audio as soon as he
walked on stage they dumped the audio so
it was all silent for us in america but
you didn't need the audio to know what
he's saying you could literally the
whole cast dakota knew what he was
saying
i've been punched on stage myself
and
if you if you put jim jeffries punched
on youtube you'll find the clip it's
from 2006 or something like that
um
and when it happened
it's it's worth the view trust me you'll
it doesn't disappoint
um but uh when it happened i remember
being so outraged and then the cop
showed up and i was like i'm going to
press charges and then i watched the
footage and i thought i'm going to make
a lot of money out of this so i'm going
to sell a few tickets
why did he run up on stage and try and
punch in the head what was going on
there
he he wasn't a heckler or anything he
was just a bloke who was on a it brought
a date and often people bring dates to
my shows and it doesn't work out well
for him you know
you should always bring a girl you've
met a few times maybe show them one of
the netflix specials ease them in it's
not good for a first date you know she
wasn't enjoying it so he thought i'll
sort this out he ran up the stage and
punched me in the head when he goes all
right dude
and after he says
keep my wife's name out of your mouth
the second time chris goes i should
all right what he just did was and i
watched it i've done as a comic your
brain was about to go i like i could
light you up way more than what i just
did i watched him physically go i don't
know what he was going to say but he did
that thing where he goes i
the dude's a pro he would dude dude oh
chris rock the dude's a pro because he
hey hey he a better man than me 100
because i would that wouldn't have been
the case he a better man than me bro
cause you know me and this dude would
have tussled
okay we would have like
will smith is a giant he's a big man in
shape he would have killed me doesn't
matter but we would have tussled we
would have gone down bradley cooper
would have had to be like you know aaron
which you would have loved you're like
cut it out coop get off of me bradley
get off me coach
this is what happens you're on right now
when you start the hashtag oscar's so
white no
[Laughter]
no one's using that today
all right we're even we got him i was
sickened by the standing ovation
i felt like hollywood is just spineless
on mass
it really felt like oh this is a really
clear indication that uh we're not the
cool club anymore we were all sickened
and those guys gave him a standing
ovation everything he said was accurate
yeah he's like i was sickened i was
sickened by the standing ovation i felt
like hollywood is just a spy is just
spineless and mass i feel like oh this
is really clear indication of what that
were not the cool club anymore jim
carrey said when asked
i didn't understand that last night but
i agree with it i didn't know how that
connected but he's right
and then he said i would have announced
this morning that i will be suing will
for 200 million because that video is
going to be there forever it's going to
be ubiquitous that insole is going to
last a very long time great oh that's
facts right there that's a great point
like
this is going to be memes it's going to
be gift everything he ever does in his
life is going to come back to this
you know the oscars already announced
that when chris rock dies that's his
in-memorium
even when he dies you're going to see
that clip bradley cooper's crying
because he's like
poor will it's like [ __ ] off dude yeah
like i totally get why these guys are
like hey i kind of don't want to get
roasted all right sure okay i get that
no no but sure so so i acknowledge that
that's fair and so then but then
that's up to the academy to figure out
this is what they should do they write
down the roast jokes they hand them to
the people you like this
what you don't what you like you don't
like because we'll take it out then they
go oh i don't really want you to talk
about my my kids done fine okay that
one's out and then we just move on from
there then we do it like that or just
don't have that
to me to me comedy died with that slap
at the oscars at the oscars yeah because
yeah but you know what fine
they want to make that show they want to
make it prestigious and all that
[Laughter]
[Music]
of our
careers in memoriam of the tradition of
the oscars really you're going to slap a
guy over a freaking gi jane joke i don't
care what happened in your life before
this or he's been making fun of will
smith and jada pickett smith's
relationship for a long time it's like
yeah because it's toxic you can
obviously see it's toxic i mean she
publicly says she cheats on you all the
time and will smith's obviously in the
closet gay which is fine just come out
be free be open be gay be happy i mean
it's literally the most toxic
relationship i've ever seen in my life
and that's coming from me
so i'm telling you i mean the fact of
the matter is this is the narcissism in
the oscars is disgusting why we are
still glorifying actors and actresses is
beyond me i mean dude a hundred years
ago the people would honor kill
themselves and their families if their
kids came out and said they were actors
i mean it's scum [ __ ] you're making
believers someone else i'm supposed to
give you a million dollars [ __ ] you i
mean what are you talking about i hate
it all i do have an audition later so
fingers crossed i get it just be honest
and be like
hey i don't like it when people [ __ ] my
wife this is really hard for me and
no i'm being serious like
if he just came out he was like
guys i've been lying to you guys
and
i don't
like it when people [ __ ] my wife
that would be the most relatable thing
that he could possibly say yeah and it's
it's it frustrates me i've tried really
hard to be okay with people [ __ ] the
dog [ __ ] out of my wife extremely
relatable yeah everyone's at home like
you're saved yeah
i do feel the same way that's a bummer
yeah
you know what it's one of my
non-negotiables yeah my life shouldn't
get [ __ ] by other people yeah yeah
and you know about it yeah oh yeah yeah
there's no way that we can control
second non-negotiable yeah like [ __ ]
don't tell them no there's no way we can
control if that happens we can only you
know
because it's if we don't know we just
don't know right but
there's no way in hell someone's gonna
be [ __ ] my wife and they're gonna
still be my wife that's just divorce
right there
so you won't be my wife you're not gonna
[ __ ] my wife and i know about it yeah
you could [ __ ] the woman i love
you
and the person i've dedicated my life to
my wife is the only thing i can control
i can remove that wife thing
and i think that's kind of what's sad
about this my buddy goes she goes he hit
her
that's where he smacks jada and i go he
hit he slaps like a man who knows how to
slap like
did not leave a mark
i i watched it a million times it's wild
first of all you can't take a hit better
than chris rock dude it did it's hands
behind you
here's the here's the argument that was
had our bus driver said uh
i know no real man is it gonna isn't
gonna um
if you start walking to me i'm gonna put
my hands up that's what's so beautiful
is chris rock really he didn't know what
he did anything he had his hands behind
his back he wasn't expecting it because
it was will smith
nobody's expecting the fresh prince to
hit you he said if it was russell crowe
marching up chris rock would have been
like
you know what i mean i mean you could
have a better luck getting hit by
lightning and chris rock thinking in
that moment he was coming to hit him he
probably thought he's gonna he's digging
into the joke even when he's walking up
he's like oh here comes king richard and
he's laughing and if you notice will
smith he he actually stays if you really
watch because i watch this thing like i
was watching tape and i was [ __ ]
mike thompson it was a brutal film yeah
he waits till the very last second and
then he he just whips it like so is that
it's unexpected he knows how to fight
you can tell will smith knows how to
fight what if he hit him in the eye and
he poked outside what if he hit him in
the temple what if he hit him and chris
rock slipped and hit his head what if he
hit him and chris rock hit him back and
they scuffled on the stage
that could have happened
the best possible outcome after that
slap is what happened it's wild chris
chris rock deserves an oscar for the way
he behaved after because he behaved
after in a manner that allows it to
escalate i'm ready for this ready i
think i think they walk backstage they
said they said would you like him
removed from the venue that's what i
think and i guarantee you that chris
rock said no
um he's going to win an oscar for king
richard uh i'm cool i'm not hurt let's
move forward let's
i guarantee you
that there's a lot that's going swept
under the under the rug that chris rock
is a little bit of a hero for this where
the [ __ ] was amy schumer and and wanda
sykes and these people to go give
somebody where are they at where they
had to come and i'd be like damn one of
our people got slapped
imagine if will smith he wouldn't have
slapped amy schumer no he wouldn't he
ain't crazy right but what if he would
have in the middle of her doing that
same joke or anything about them when
keep my wife's name out your [ __ ]
mouth if you would have done that oh oh
today
he'd be done yeah they would have cooked
them he would he would they would have
cooked them on was it was that smell is
that well
they would have cooked his hair
is that will smith i mean what else was
there to think it's so and then what
about the other con some comics just
like typing in all capital letters for
like three days in a row and it's like
all right
are you really this upset are you trying
to get some of this stink on you so you
can sell some more [ __ ] tickets there
you go
[ __ ] [ __ ] three days in a row
three days in a row you sustain that
level listen you might hear some things
that you don't like
and you will stay in your [ __ ] seats
i'm not saying that i can fight
i will bite your [ __ ] nose off
i'll fight your tits off
all these people who are like you know
like it's women too like
i want a man to protect me like that oh
so you want a man to embarrass himself
on his biggest moment in his life yeah
you want a man to go to jail for you so
you want a man to look like a [ __ ]
idiot on national television for you
who's that for huh who's that for all
these women out here like i need a man
like that no you don't you need a man
that knows how to control his [ __ ]
temper right protect you when you need
to be protected when someone is
physically assaulting you or or trying
to physically threaten you that's not
the same thing easily could have stepped
to chris afterwards at the variety fair
party 100 homie come here for a second
can we talk yeah see i feel like you got
an issue with my family can we talk
about this that's how you do it yeah
even if backstage you would have been
like yo man if they would have been like
will smith got into a shouting match
with chris rock
backstage we would have been like oh
maybe he took a fist of that you
probably would have taken will's side
you know what if he went backstage and
you heard will smith got in his face and
was like don't ever talk about my
[ __ ] family ever again you'd have
probably gone
damn i keep saying this ain't about no
protecting my wife no no it's not this
is about
right it's about have some decorum man
yeah have some class [ __ ] it's
so funny to me that hollywood was
demanding that the ukrainian president
be invited to the ceremony so we could
stand with them in like civilized
solidarity
and then this is what happens at this is
the event it would be like if you had
like
you know your wedding
at your wedding two two of the groomsmen
got into a fight or something you know
what i mean it's so embarrassing if i'm
on the street and chris rock comes up to
makes a joke about my wife
who has a condition i'm going to slap
chris rock
if in the context of the awards he's a
comedian that rift a joke that may not
have known about our condition that also
by the way jada i think was online
saying like you know what i got a humor
all you can do is laugh i'm gonna shave
my head you know
it's no big deal i accept it you know
always be he was like i love you can't
wait to see you in in gi jane three it's
almost just like she shaved her head you
shaved your head you're a bad you're a
badass you could be in that it was
almost like borderline of like was it
supposed to be an insult to her i don't
i don't know if it was i think it was
just a dumb joke like you shaved your
head but then
laughing it was a will laugh which is
the creepiest thing no it's not creepy
yeah it's creepy to me like this he went
and then you see him kind of look over
at her and she's rolling her eyes that's
when the moment and then like the dragon
but he was they dealing with some chris
rock just was in the way 100 i know it
wasn't that was it wasn't
he was like you know he did something or
well you know there's all those rumors
that she was you know [ __ ] one of
jaden's friends or some [ __ ] like
all day businesses in the street how was
your weekend
[Applause]
i'm not i don't have like a bunch of
[ __ ]
about what happened
so if you came to hear that i'm not i
had like a whole show i wrote before
this
weekend
and i'm still kind of processing
what happened like
like
so
that's so important
more comedians reacted on twitter mark
norman had one of my favorite tweets he
said we should change karen to jada
david spade said a gi jane joke theovan
said black on black crime at the oscars
then he tweeted i'm surprised amy
schumer didn't stand up for rock then he
quote tweeted himself saying actually
i'm not ian edward said this is why i
don't watch the oscars too much violence
christa stefano who we heard from in
that video also tweeted babe truthfully
the toxicity in will and jay's
relationship is palpable that is the
story they need to divorce let him come
out as gay so he calms down and finds
peace and she can go eat the next soul
nicki glazer said i'm sad we miss the
rest of rock's jokes which is very true
no one ever talks about that i'm sure he
had some other great jokes um about bald
people in the audience jim norton said
at this point will smith being a cuck is
the only thing i truly respect him for
and chris stefano also tweeted the fact
that will smith didn't get led away in
handcuffs and said was applauded by his
peers is the ultimate white privilege if
you love comedy make sure you subscribe
to this channel joke world and follow us
on instagram for more daily comedy
content comment which comedian you
thought had the funniest reaction to
this event and we'll see you next time
with another video
[Music]
you